Arby is there anyone who pitched you
recently or in the last few years that
you met on social media and they said
you know I want to come work for stage
32 I want to work for you yeah it
happens often and we actually did hire
somebody off of social media when I say
office social media is somebody that I
had met on social media and that the
staff was familiar with in social media
who was also a member of stage 32 for a
while and the thing that was attractive
about that person besides the skill set
but the what made us want to look deeper
into him was the fact that he had spent
months cultivating relationships not
only with me and members of my staff but
with people on the site and then we were
able to look at how he handled himself
on other social media accounts that he
was listed on and you know I have a
saying that you know don't do anything
online that you wouldn't do in the
quote/unquote real world you know a lot
of people get big balls behind the
computer screen we call it big ball
syndrome right and they do you know and
they think it's okay you know to act
like an ass more or less and it comes
back to bite you it really does because
you know people are going to look at how
you handle yourself and it's not just me
as an employer it's me as a producer you
know somebody approaches me and says
knows I'm involved with a project and
says I'm an actor you know maybe you
should look at me and I go and I do some
research on that person and it's not
only you know they they have the
performances are okay they have their
reels and you know like I spoke about
earlier even you do get some people that
don't even do that you'll get I actually
have somebody to hit me up and said you
know I'm an actor take a look at my
profile I went to the profile and on the
bio it literally said I'm an actor okay
and it was like well fantastic
congratulations you and everybody else
and he has no reels up and nothing but
take the person that has the completed
bio and all the you know all the media
that he should have up there he or she
you know I want to look a little deeper
I want to make sure that this person is
going to be a collaborator on the set is
not going to be completely self-serving
it's going to have the best interests of
his other actors at heart you know when
you're doing sides I mean when you know
you're doing close-ups and he needs to
be you know he's off camera and he's
assisting the other you could tell a lot
by the way a person handles handles
himself online you so you go a little
bit
so this particular person I was talking
about that we hired everything that he
had done online showed how he would be
or at least I felt proved to me how he
would be in an office environment simply
because he constantly gave he constantly
asked questions he was constantly
offering posting great content
retweeting other people's content
sharing liking commenting it matters it
makes a big difference and that was one
of the that you know besides his skill
set which was similar to other people
who had applied for the job that was
something that pushed it over the top
for us going back to what you said about
big balls syndrome which it's a great
name what if that's part of someone's
whole shtick what if they're like you
know what I just tell it like it is and
I have no filter and if people are
offended well that's their problem which
you hear that and there's many different
thoughts on all that yeah but if that's
their thing how should they then temper
that for the internet or maybe they
shouldn't well I don't think they should
if that's the way they are in real life
I like you know I've never been accused
of being shy I'm pretty blunt you know
but I like to say that I'm simply honest
I'm respectful about it you know I'm not
going to go out there and call anybody
names would be abusive or you know if I
get into debate I'm gonna be honest
about the debate I'm not gonna be you
know name-calling or anything like that
but I mean if you're full of bluster and
you're full of energy and this is the
person that you are offline then that's
fine if that's your persona online you
just have to be careful because you know
the one the one exception two things
offline an online is that that you know
nothing replaces that face-to-face
interaction of course so things can get
misconstrued online you know it's like I
said I tell people all the time with
emails because I try to stay off email
as much as possible and you face-to-face
interaction even if it's through Skype
or through GoToMeeting because I want to
be able to see the person's expression
because you know I have a great deal of
sarcasm and I try I my own sense of
humor and sometimes gets lost in email
people think all of a sudden like oh my
god you mad at me and I'm like I'm not
mad at you I'm just I'm cracking a joke
you know but so you know it's the only
thing I have to be careful about but if
you're consistent in your behavior I
think it you know people on this
and realize it and then going back to
the gentleman that you hired after
seeing that he was a giver online and
and kind of checking him out aside from
seeing that he was generous with his
retweeting you saw that his bio and
everything was in line it seems like
that that what did you call it the full
circle you get a greaser closing the
circle I like that
yeah great yeah he had all that and they
mean he had his resume up and this was
somebody was also creative as well so he
had a resume for his work you know what
it was work life so you know quote
unquote work life and then he had his
resume and experience for his creative
life the things that he was doing as a
producer and as a filmmaker and things
of that nature that was also interesting
for me to see because I was able to look
at him through sort of two different
lenses and you know take a look at his
work career take a look at what I mean
this is his work career as well but he
wasn't doing this full-time it wasn't
enough to support him full-time so he
was doing this other work but to be able
to see that he got it and that he
understood it I mean we were a social
media company or an educational an
education company we want people that
fall into that realm and he had done a
lot of the social media work he had done
some teaching before and then plus he
fit the description of what we were
looking for him to do as far as the
day-to-day and in what the role that he
was looking to fill right and in terms
of having two accounts let's say one
word that's your work life and one
that's the fun out of work you know we
all can be sarcastic we all can be silly
yeah but then keeping in mind like you
know I I don't drink and tweet you know
different things that like so we don't
get too out of control cuz we all can go
there I mean we're all human we can all
push the boundaries and then go you know
what I didn't really mean that right
drunk tweeting well you know I mean look
everybody has personal life - sorry and
I think that you know again as long as
you're staying true to who you are
that's okay but I do believe that people
don't realize sometimes that you are
being looked at on social media like you
know if you are applying for a job or
even if you're you're you know looking
to fill a role on a set you know and
people have options
they are gonna look they really do I
mean I've I was down south by southwest
and I spoke to so many
filmmakers and producers that when I
talked about rounding outcasts and
things like that I can't tell you how
many I mentioned I do my research on
social media I look at what people do I
look at how they have excuse me how they
handle themselves I look at what they
post they look at their reels you know
and make sure that it's there that
everything is there because I don't have
time to waste
and I don't want poison on my set and it
used to be like I said in the old days
you took a shot you know somebody would
give you a referral or somebody you know
you heard about a good you know person
in town or whatever but now it's much
much more competitive because if I'm a
filmmaker in LA or you know let's take
me out of LA if I'm a filmmaker in you
know Omaha okay I can go onto social
media and find cast and crew in Omaha
there's a bunch of different sites even
outside of stationary to where I could
probably look around go onto LinkedIn or
whatever you know not that I recommend
that but but you understand my point is
that the pool is bigger so why shouldn't
I be a little bit more selective and why
shouldn't I bet people before they're
poison on my set
you